tant qu'elle prendra y compris dans le
brouhaha mesdames et messieurs les
députés si nécessaire elle prendra le
temps qu'elle prendra cette discussion
parce que nous respectons le parlement
nous respectons le parlement et nous
respectons les moyens de l'opposition
même lorsque ces moyens ne sont pas mis
au service de la progression du débat et
j'espère que mes collègues qui me
suivront pour en parler dans autre chose
qu'un boa immense que celui que vous
offrez aujourd'hui à la représentation
nationale
quoi qu'il en soit cette discussion doit
marquer une nouvelle étape
chacun dans son rôle chacun dans ses
prérogatives l'ambition que porte le
gouvernement est triple construire un
système universel qui est sûr chaque
français et où tout le monde doit être
assurée quel que soit son parcours et
quelle que soit sa position prendre en
compte les trajectoires de vie en
déplaçant notre regard du statut vers
l'activité et enfin ce système doit
mobiliser de nouveaux leviers comme la
prévention ou le droit à la reconversion
pour les métiers les plus pénibles parce
que oui il faut le dire le système
actuel laisse au bord du chemin les plus
fragiles de nos concitoyens les moins
représentées il attend souvent trop
longtemps pour réparer au lieu de
prévenir journée pour mener à bien cette
ambition nous nous armons d'un principe
celui de l'universalité l'universalité
c'est un beau mot l'universalité est une
exigence la solidarité c'est un très
beau mot le mot de solidarité et d'un
état d'esprit la responsabilité
l'universalité n'est pas d'ailleurs
qu'un mot c'est le pilier de la
protection sociale que nous construisons
l'universalité que nous défendons ce
n'est pas un universalisme abstrait qui
refuseraient de considérer les
différences de fait entre les personnes
les parcours et les situations
nous pouvons et nous devons à la fois
proposer un régime universel est uni
recompter des parcours de vie de chacun
ce régime universel permet de sortir des
logiques professionnelle qui crée tantôt
de la défiance
tantôt de la suspicion parce qu'il en
est ainsi dès que l'on pense que ne pas
être logé à la même enseigne que son
voisin
c'était le dessin des pères fondateurs
de la sécurité sociale l'ordonnancé de
1945 portant organisation de la sécurité
sociale prévoyaient ainsi que parmi
celles jouissant déjà d'un régime
spécial demeure provisoirement
provisoirement soumise à une
organisation spéciale de sécurité
sociale les branches d'activité ou
entreprise énumérés par un décret en
conseil d'état
75 ans est un provisoire qui a duré
cette situation le premier à l'avoir
déploré s'était d'ailleurs pierre
laroque qui revenant sur la création
historique de la sécurité sociale
regretter l'échec à l'époque d'un régime
unique
je le cite ce plan dans ce qu'ils
pouvaient avoir de révolutionnaire par
sa volonté d'affirmer une solidarité
nationale a néanmoins buté sur
l'obstacle de structures sociales
existantes qui se sont révélés par fois
plus puissantes que les forces du
renouvellement la voix d'ambroise
croizat résonne encore alors qu'il
rappelait le 8 août 1946 à cette même
tribune
l'ambition de la sécurité sociale
ambition de permettre à tous les
individus de développer au maximum leurs
moyens propres n'imaginait pas cette
ambition réalisable dans une
multiplicité d'institutions parce que
disait-il et je le cite à nouveau la
caisse unique est la condition
indispensable de toute sécurité sociale
digne de ce nom
nous ne défendons pas eu notre position
aujourd'hui que celle des pères
fondateurs de la sécurité sociale et ce
d'autant plus que la sécurité sociale
est une promesse qui pourraient être
tenues doit s'adapter aux réalités
nouvelles
parce que oui nous voulons une
protection sociale plus robustes plus
universel mieux adapté au monde
d'aujourd'hui
le monde d'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une
expression ce sont des parcours de vie h
et ce sont des carrières moins linéaire
et ce sont de nouveaux risques qui
n'était pas identifié hier et qui se
présente à nous aujourd'hui avec force
l'universalité est un principe qui
permet l'adhésion la lisibilité en un
mot la confiance mais je les dis nous ne
versons pas dans un universalisme
abstrait nous voulons l'égalité mais
nous savons aussi qu'une égalité aveugle
aux différences est injuste et même
parfois dangereuses la question des
solidarités à présent pour conjurer ce
risque
nous devons inventer de nouvelles
solidarités pas des solidarités qui se
substituent aux anciennes non des
solidarités qui les complète que les
élargissent pour protéger toujours
davantage les français des situations
nouvelles nous oblige aujourd'hui à
aller vers des populations fragiles à
identifier des situations de
vulnérabilité pour construire des
politiques sociales adaptées à ces
réalités individuelles le monde du
travail je les dis n'est plus pour tout
le monde celui où l'on franchisse et des
portes d'une entreprise pour y passer
toute sa carrière le monde du travail
d'hier a pu justifier l'organisation
professionnelle du système de retraite
et la multiplication du nombre de
régimes tenir compte des instabilités
c'est comprendre que si certains sont à
l'aise dans la mondialisation et n'ont
finalement pas tant vu leur parcours
modifié d'autres en subissent les
conséquences et ressentent au mieux de
le mettre de l'amertume au pire de la
souffrance là où les fragilités et et
transversales collective
interprofessionnelle
elles sont aujourd'hui multiples et
individuels et bien souvent vécue dans
l' isolement identifier ses fragilités
nouvelle les anticiper les prévenir
c'est l'enjeu majeur de notre protection
sociale et notre système de retraites ne
doit pas devenir l'angle mort d'une
protection sociale qui ne serait pas
adapté à la vie des français je pense en
particulier à tout ce qui dans le
système actuel sont défavorisés et
parfois même oublié c'est le cas des
femmes et nous savons qu'aujourd'hui les
pensions des femmes sont très largement
inférieure à celle des hommes presque de
moitié alors même qu'elles partent
souvent beaucoup plus tard ce qui est
inacceptable
nous tiendrons au mieux compte de la
maternité et du nombre d'enfants pour
permettre aux femmes qui parfois
s'arrêtent de travailler pour élever
leurs enfants d'accéder à un meilleur
niveau de pension
la solidarité c'est aussi
nous payons pas de mots faire contribuer
chacun selon ses moyens à la solidarité
nationale pour financer des mesures de
solidarité pour tout le monde à
commencer par les plus fragiles de nos
concitoyens au registre des solidarités
je pense évidemment à tous ceux qui
après avoir travaillé toute leur vie se
retrouvent fatigué avec une pension de
misère
ce sont les agriculteurs ce sont ces
artisans ce sont ces commerçants
auxquels nous garantirons demain une
pension minimale de 1000 2000 euros les
gens qui touchent aujourd'hui 700 euros
et qui demain pourront toucher grâce à
la réforme que vous allez voter mesdames
et messieurs les députés je l'espère
nombreux percevront un minimum de 1000
euros penser à ces personnes moment vous
criez mesdames et messieurs de
l'opposition
pensez à ces personnes qui attendent
cette réforme par ses propositions par
cette proposition
nous tenons la promesse du préambule de
la constitution de 1946 qui prévoyait
que quiconque se trouvant en raison de
son âge dans l'incapacité de travailler
aura le droit d'obtenir de la
collectivité des moyens convenables
d'existence
enfin la responsabilité
l'universalité et notre principe les
solidarités son autre exigence commune
j'en viens à l'état d'esprit que la
responsabilité ce n'est pas une option
j'ai déjà évoqué les jeunes de notre
pays parce que notre système de retraite
laisse souvent pour le mot clé est que
notre système de retraite laisse pour le
moins dubitatif il faut leur redonner à
ces jeunes de la confiance parce que
sans une jeunesse qui regardent l'avenir
avec sérénité
le pacte entre les générations pourrait
être rompu la responsabilité c'est aussi
de dire que les français sont lassés de
voir des réformes paramétriques à
intervalles réguliers des réformes qui
court après l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie et qui laisse à
chacun un sentiment d'inachevé et dîna
cheval
une concertation est en cours avec les
partenaires sociaux pour définir les
modalités de rééquilibrage du système de
retraite d'ici à 2027
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
projet que nous vous présentons est un
projet annoncé de longue date
ce projet a la légitimité d'un programme
présidentiel
il a la légitimité d'une concertation et
la légitimité d'un rapport préparatoire
conduite sous l'égide de jean paul ii le
voir et j'espère qu'il aura demain la
légitimité large accordée par la
confiance des parlementaires de
nouvelles garanties ont été annoncées
par le premier ministre en matière de
transition concernant l'emploi des
seniors et la pénibilité
des amendements ont été déposés pour
enrichir les dispositifs permettant de
compenser les préjudices de carrière des
femmes liées à la naissance et à
l'éducation des enfants
ces évolutions renforce le volet
solidarité du projet de réforme des
retraites
des discussions se poursuivent encore
sur la prévention de la pénibilité sur
le financement et sur l'équilibrage du
régime
les partenaires sociaux doivent en effet
être force de proposition c'est beau la
démocratie sociale ne devrait pas vous
faire peur monsieur vélo elle est belle
la démocratie sociale c'est l'objectif
même d'ailleurs de la gouvernance que
nous allons mettre en place
n empêche pas la démocratie
parlementaire nous sommes ici pour
démontrer interrompre les pales orateurs
cet exercice renouvelée de la démocratie
sociale
diluez monsieur le ministre monsieur lui
regarder droit devant et continuer merci
monsieur président
[Applaudissements]
je m'étonne que ce qui vous fasse urnes
et le plus c'est l'évocation du fait
qu'on va confier à la démocratie sociale
le soin de faire des propositions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'objectif même je le disais la
gouvernance que nous allons mettre en
place mais cet exercice renouveler la
démocratie sociale dont nous avons je
crois grandement besoin
il n'est pas incompatible avec
l'exercice de la démocratie
parlementaire
les mesures qui ferait l'objet d'un
accord avec les partenaires sociaux
trouveront bien naturellement leur place
dans la loi et dans le débat
parlementaire
tout comme les propositions des
partenaires sociaux dans le système
universel seront bien évidemment validé
par le parlement
en tout cas examinés pour l'être dans
l'exercice de son pouvoir démocratique
souverain parce que la retraite c'est
avant tout une protection sociale et la
promesse que chacun d'entre nous aura
les moyens de vivre correctement en
quittant sa vie professionnelle par le
système universel nous voulons répondre
à la demande de justice et d'égalité
devant la retraite elle a été exprimée
par les citoyens tout au long de la
démarche de participation sur la réforme
face à l'instabilité des parcours face
aux incertitudes de l'avenir plus forte
aujourd'hui que par le passé la
protection sociale est plus que jamais
un cadre de référence et de stabilité
dans un monde qui désarçonne la
stabilité n'est pas seulement une
attente légitime
c'est aussi une demande nécessaire et
nous devons y répondre
j'ai cité pierre laroque j'ai cité
ambroise croizat ces sites et michel
rocard
je sais ce que nous devons aux pères
fondateurs la sécurité sociale et ceux
qui leur ont succédé
et autant vous dire qu'on leur doit
énormément c'est un projet de loi que je
crois sincèrement fidèle aux valeurs
fondatrices que nous présentons
aujourd'hui un projet porteur de grandes
ambitions pour protéger les français de
manière plus juste et plus efficace
comme ministre en charge de la sécurité
sociale je défendrai l'unification des
2022 du pilotage dans les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale du
financement des dépenses des régimes de
base et complémentaires du risque
vieillesse seul moyen de donner une
réalité financière au système universel
vis-à-vis du parlement et de nos
concitoyens je défends ce texte avec la
conviction qu'il sera à la hauteur de
notre attachement indéfectible à la
solidarité et du combat que nous menons
sans relâche pour la justice sociale
je vous remercie or si monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur laurent
pietrasinski secrétaire d'état chargé
des retraites
[Applaudissements]
bien merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre des solidarités de
la santé madame la présidente de la
commission spéciale mesdames et
messieurs et rapporteur et dams et
messieurs les députés
le débat qui s'ouvre dans cet hémicycle
est l'un des plus importants de ces
dernières années
s'agit de refonder notre système de
retraite pour le corriger des nombreuses
injustices qu'il produit nous portons le
projet d'un système universel un système
capable de s'adapter au fil du temps et
en permanence aux évolutions sociales à
la transformation des métiers et des
parcours professionnels et de s'adapter
aussi à son environnement économique
ce projet s'inscrit dans notre ambition
pour notre pays
celle d'organiser une protection sociale
pour aujourd'hui pour demain pour nos
parents pour nous mêmes pour nos enfants
c'est avec cet objectif que le
gouvernement entend réformer notre
système de retraite
c'est l'engagement que nous avions pris
devant les français
mettre en place un système universel
juste transparent fiable où chacun
bénéficiera des mêmes droits
tout en prenant en compte les
spécificités des métiers après le temps
de la démocratie sociale et de la
concertation avec les citoyens
après le temps de la commission spéciale
voici le temps du débat et de l'examen
par la représentation nationale que vous
êtes sous le regard attentif des
français nous voulons transformer le
pays pour le rendre plus juste plus fort
afin de recréer la confiance et le
consensus social nous avons réformé avec
succès le dialogue social
l'apprentissage la formation
professionnelle l'assurance chômage nous
voulons désormais refonder notre système
de retraite
alors c'est vrai mais d'amélie pts et la
retraite suscite le gouvernement le sel
de l'inquiétude chez nos concitoyens et
c'est normal puisque nous parlons de
ceux qui procurent 80% des ressources
des français quand ils ne sont plus en
âge de travailler
j'affirme donc ici devant vous que le
système universel de retraite sera plus
juste plus efficace et améliorera je le
montrerai tout au long des débats la
situation de la plupart des français
rien ne serait pire mesdames et
messieurs les députés pour notre avenir
et celui de nos enfants que de nous
enfermer dans un conservatisme craintifs
qui peut croire aujourd'hui que la
france de demain sera celle du siècle
dernier
qui peut croire que les métiers vont
continuer à s'organiser autour de ce
statut qui permettent à certains de
bénéficier davantage dans les autres
sont privés
qui peut croire qu'à l'heure où on
changera plusieurs fois d'emploi de
statut au cours d'une vie que certaines
professions pourrait encore s'extraire
de la solidarité nationale pour
s'enfermer dans un égoïsme frileux
personne ne peut de bonne foi soutenir
de telles orientations
mesdames et messieurs les députés nos
prédécesseurs ont mené des réformes
courageuses mais toujours d'inspiration
budgétaire pour confirmer notre système
pour le conforter qui avec une durée
d'assurance qui sur les âges de départ
notre lecture est plus large
notre ambition dépasse l'équilibré
budgétaire c'est une refondation sociale
que le gouvernement porte devant vous ce
projet de loi est organisée en 65
articles répartis en cinq titres
permettez-moi de revenir quelques
instants sur ses cinq titres
le titre imprécises des grands principes
du système universel il en détail
l' architecture juridique et précise des
principaux paramètres en matière de
cotisations d'acquisition des points et
de calcul des droits
il prévoit la création d'un âge
déquilibre destiné à inciter les
français sans les y contraindre à
travailler un peu plus longtemps
c'est également dans ce titre que se
trouve l'engagement du gouvernement à
revaloriser les carrières des
enseignants et des enseignants
chercheurs le titre deux incarnent
l'esprit de liberté et de justice que
porte le gouvernement carte
la liberté c'est le choix de pouvoir
partir des 62 ans comme c'est aussi la
possibilité de travailler à un peu plus
longtemps pour augmenter sa pension tout
en garantissant la solidité du système
qui nous unit c'est aussi la
reconnaissance de situations difficiles
au travail liées à des activités qui
pourraient avoir des répercussions sur
la santé
c'est enfin la reconnaissance de
nouveaux parcours de vie où les temps
d'activité de repos devront mieux
s'harmoniser
la société doit permettre une transition
douce entre l'activité et la retraite et
reconnaître ainsi l'importance des
seniors dans l'activité productive de
notre pays et aussi dans notre tissu
social
le titre trois portes les différents
dispositifs de solidarité
on y trouve le minimum de retraite à
1000 euros dès 2022 et à 85% du smic
pour toutes celles et ceux qui auront
une carrière complète y compris dans le
système futur pour la majorité des temps
partiels
mesdames et messieurs les députés à
l'heure où 30% des retraités ont une
pension inférieure à 1000 euros
c'est une conquête sociale majeure que
le gouvernement vous propose d'adopter
soyons en fiers
ce titre iii sera débattue mais aussi je
l'espère fera l'objet d'un large
consensus avec vous mesdames et
messieurs les députés
s'agissant de la question des aidants et
des droits pour les personnes en
situation de handicap ainsi que sur la
réversion les droits familiaux et la
réversion seront profondément modernisée
dans ce texte
s'agissant des enfants le projet
recentre le dispositif sur le préjudice
de carrière des femmes et organise une
meilleure répartition de ces droits
entre toutes les familles la réversion
est remaniée et devient une garantie de
niveau de vie pour le conjoint survivant
à partir de 55 ans et sans condition de
ressources
l'examen de ce titre sera l'occasion de
faire évoluer le texte initial
conformément aux annonces du
gouvernement de la semaine dernière et à
la co construction de solutions avec les
parlementaires et les partenaires
sociaux
le titre quatre concerne la gouvernance
il traite de l'organisation financière
du nouveau système de son pilotage
c'est une refondation du paritarisme à
la française est une reconnaissance du
rôle des parlementaires que vous êtes
nous aurions pu rester dans le confort
du système actuel mais oui il nous faut
réinventer ensemble le système de demain
alors vous n'avez interrogé en
commission sur les enjeux budgétaires du
futur système mais parlons d'abord de la
réalité du système actuel si vous le
voulez bien la réalité du système actuel
c'est près de 12 milliards d'euros de
déficit à l'horizon 2027
je veux le papa des déficits de 2026 de
2025 et des années précédentes
il est de notre responsabilité
collective d'y répondre
si le titre cinq prévoient les
conditions d'entrée en vigueur et de
transition vers un système universel
c'est dans ce titre que sera traitée la
question de la garantie à 100% des
droits du passé lié à la carrière
préalable à l'entrée en vigueur du
système universel
alors je veux être clair devant vous
mesdames et messieurs les députés
le gouvernement tient sa parole tient sa
parole donnée aux français aux
partenaires sociaux tous les droits qui
seront convertis en fin de carrière
nous l'avons dit et rappelé la semaine
dernière mesdames et messieurs les
députés dans un monde en mouvement la
retraite de demain doit être appréhendée
dans la confiance et dans la
transparence
elle ne doit plus être soumises aux
aléas de la croissance et de la
démographie de certaines professions de
certains statuts à doit être équitable
pour toutes et pour tous plus solide et
adaptée aux transformations du monde du
travail que nous vivons dès aujourd'hui
nous le devons à nos compatriotes à
l'ère de la défiance dans la parole
publique
il nous faut améliorer concrètement leur
vie et ne pas tomber dans le jeu les
promesses démagogiques et intenable jean
paul delevoye que je veux saluer ici a
voulu innover dans la préparation de ce
texte
en associant très en amont les
parlementaires de toute la jeune
majorité bien au-delà de sa majorité
naturel de la république en marche avec
le modem et agir
j'ai une pensée pour tous ces
parlementaires qui ont été animées sur
leur territoire et ailleurs les ateliers
citoyens afin d'échanger avec les
habitants de leur territoire et remonter
leurs attentes auprès du gouvernement
ce sont des centaines de réunions
publiques parfois troublée par des
opposants violents qui ont pu se tenir
partout dans notre pays
ce projet de loi c'est aussi surtout
améliorer la vraie vie des gens
la vraie vie c'est celle de toutes ces
femmes qui ont connu des carrières
hachées
parce qu'elles ont dû élever seule leurs
enfants et qu'elles n'ont pas
véritablement eu d'autre choix que
d'exercer des métiers difficiles ou
précaires dans le système actuel
mesdames et messieurs les députés
celui que certains de manière
incompréhensible
parfois vous défendez un doivent ses
fans attendre 67 ans pour partir à taux
plein comme 120000 français elles sont
80 mille femmes chaque année
à devoir aller jusqu'à 67 ans pour
atteindre l'âge d'annulation de la
décote
comment pouvez vous défendre un tel
système
demain ces femmes bénéficieront de l'âge
d'équilibré pourront partir à taux plein
64 ans car oui les carrières des femmes
ont changé lé taux d'activité se rejoint
et je m'en félicite
mais les niveaux de pension actuelle
accentue les inégalités
le système universel devra y remédier
car oui universelle c'est aussi celui de
l'équité la vraie vie c'est celle de ces
agriculteurs qui ont du mal à se payer
tous les mois qui travaillent sans
compter leurs heures par passion autant
que par héritage d'une certaine idée de
la terre demain grâce au système
universel
les nouveaux retraités auront un minimum
de pension à 85% du smic
cette conquête sociale majeure que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
pourtant voté dès 2003 parfait assemblée
mais jamais mise en oeuvre
nous le ferons nous dès le 1er janvier
fidèle à notre attachement aux droits
réels sur les droits formels
car oui le système universel c'est celui
de la justice sociale la vraie vie c'est
celle de ces enseignants au niveau
d'études élevé dont la trajectoire
salariale et les parcours professionnels
sont souvent mal reconnus
historiquement au moins pris mais que
les autres fonctionnaires parce que la
règle des six derniers mois
permettait d'effacer les différences de
pension avec les catégories équivalente
demain grâce à notre projet l'éducation
nationale aura revu sa grille de
rémunération et 2021 ce sont 500
millions d'euros qui seront mobilisés
pour les enseignants
oui mesdames et messieurs les députés de
voulons investir sur cette profession
qui est au fondement de nos contrat
social trop longtemps délaissé par ceux
qui aujourd'hui crient sur certains de
ses banques c'est le sens de notre
action depuis 2017
je veux ici saluer le travail les
engagements de jean michel blanquer de
frédéric vidal
car oui le système universel engage la
refondation des métiers des enseignants
et des chercheurs
la vraie vie c'est celle aussi des
collaborateurs d'entreprises aux régimes
spéciaux certains s'opposent à la
réforme oui mais pourquoi parce qu'ils
sont dans une entreprise dont le contrat
social doit désormais évoluer il est
temps d'y prendre en compte la
pénibilité en anticipant lorsque c'est
nécessaire le départ en retraite mais
aussi en améliorant la qualité de vie au
travail en prenant en compte les risques
spécifiques propres à ces métiers
ce n'est pas une question de statut
c'est avant tout une question de
dialogue social dès 2022
nous organiserons pour les métiers à
risques visite médicale obligatoire à 55
ans pour repérer les problèmes de santé
et en cas d'incapacité les assurés
pourront bénéficier de départs anticipés
des 60 ans à taux plein dès 2022 les
branches professionnelles négocieront
des actions de prévention car oui le
système universel c'est aussi celui qui
laisse de la place à la négociation
sociale
la vraie vie c'est aussi celle de ses
cadres à l'expérience si précieuse pour
nos entreprises à la proche de la
retraite ils ne veulent pas faire été
tout de suite mais se verrait bien
moduler leur plan de travail
alors dès 2022 la retraite progressive
sera un droit pour eux un droit comme
pour les autres salariés
un droit opposable à tous car oui le
système universel c'est celui de la
liberté du choix du départ la vraie vie
c'est celle de tous ceux qui multiplient
les métiers dans une france où l'on
changera si souvent d'emplois au cours
de sa carrière
ces français qui ont cotisé à tellement
de régimes différents qui ne savent plus
trop comment s'y prendre pour se
préparer à cette retraite et pour
liquider le moment venu leurs droits à
pension
demain le système universel permettra
d'avoir un seul interlocuteur à une
seule retraite car oui le système
universel c'est celui de la lisibilité
et d'un meilleur service apporté aux
français alors mesdames et messieurs les
députés
ce ne sont que quelques exemples nous
devrons aussi parler aux cours donnés
aux débats de nombreuses autres
situations comme par exemple celle des
intérimaires des femmes à temps partiel
des travailleurs en situation de
handicap et j'en oublie mais les débats
seront longs et je l'espère riches
je voudrais terminer en saluant les
membres de la commission spéciale lors
se son discours face au conseil
économique social et environnemental en
décembre dernier le premier ministre
avait fixé un calendrier très clair
après plus de deux ans de préparation le
temps d'avancer était venu une
présentation en conseil des ministres
fin janvier un examen en séance publique
en février pour l adoption définitive
d'ici à l'été
les mêmes qui nous reprochaient d'aller
trop lentement nous reproche d'aller
trop vite maintenant le gouvernement
assume son calendrier nous ne voulons
pas aller vite ou lentement
nous voulons porter un projet de
programme c'est le sens que j'ai donnée
aux 75 heures consacrées à la commission
spéciale avec l'ensemble de ses
participants quels que soient leur
groupe politique d'origine
je veux souligner le travail de fond
mené par la plupart des députés et la
qualité des échanges que j'ai pu avoir
durant ses jours et ses nuits avec
l'ensemble des groupes politiques mais
nous le savons nous examinons ce texte
dans des conditions très particulières
certains groupes politiques ont fait le
choix assumé une opposition qui refusent
de débats pour se contenter du refus
un reflux qui sauvent systématique un
refus qui prend la forme d'une
obstruction vous plaît un refus qui
s'attachait ligne par ligne
alinéa par alinéa sens pour le texte le
droit d'amendement
mesdames et messieurs les députés était
un droit constitutionnel que je respecte
bien entendu mais prenons garde que
l'obstruction mécanique ne transforme
certains députés au robot d'une
organisation terroriste d'obstruction je
le dis sans animosité
ce n'est pas ma conception du débat
démocratique
alors je lis la presse comme tout le
monde
et j'entends que certains groupes vont
tenter au delà du nombre invraisemblable
d'amendements déposés dont certains sont
un intérêt douteux de nouvelles
manoeuvres d'obstruction
ils doivent savoir que le gouvernement
aborde ces débats avec sérénité
alors où notre pays est traversé par les
fractures
à l'heure où les piliers fondamentaux
s'efface dangereusement et alors que la
violence si miss parfois dans les
permanences d'élus et nous appartient de
montrer par la qualité de nos débats de
notre écoute mutuelle la vitalité de
notre démocratie parlementaire dames et
messieurs les députés
il ya trois ans le citoyen que je suis
qui n'avait connu aucune expérience
politique a fait le choix comme d'autres
sur ses bancs de s'engager dans la vie
citoyenne je les fais comme nous tous
ici je crois avec la volonté de
transformer le pays la force des
convictions et le goût du débat
mesdames et messieurs les députés ne
donnons pas à voir ce que nous ne sommes
pas la grandeur de l'action politique
c'est de donner du sens au projet
collectif
je vous ai exposé le projet et les
convictions
qui s'y rattachent pour ce projet de loi
le système universel de retraites et le
projet de la refondation de notre pacte
entre les générations pour préserver
notre système par répartition je formule
des eaux mais désormais le voeu d'un
débat passionné vif mais serein et
respectueux le temps du système
universel de retraite est venu à nous de
le construire
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur guillaume
gouffier chat rapporteur de la
commission spéciale dont cinq minutes
sauf rapporteur monsieur le président
messieurs les mini chez un laurent
pietra jet ski chez olivier ferrand
madame la présidente brigitte
bourguignon mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
après plus de 70 heures de débat en
commission spéciale et plus de 7000 est
même en discuter nous voici réunis pour
poursuivre nos travaux en séance
si la commission n'a pas réussi à
terminer l'examen du texte dans son
ensemble tous les sujets ont été abordés
et discutés
nous avons notamment pu réaffirmer notre
engagement revaloriser les revenus des
enseignants et des enseignants
chercheurs l'importance de mieux prendre
en compte les aidants familiaux et les
parents ayant des enfants en situation
de handicap
notre volonté d'améliorer les droits
familiaux
nous avons aussi apporté des précisions
nécessaires concernant les règles de
fonctionnement du futur système
universel de retraite
nous avons notamment précisé que
l'indicateur de référence qui permettra
de revaloriser la valeur du point
reposera sur la moyenne par tête des
revenus d'activité c'est-à-dire des
salaires du privé des traitements des
agents de la fonction publique et des
revenus des indépendants et des libéraux
cet indicateur sera toujours bien plus
favorable que l'indexation sur
l'inflation en vigueur depuis trente ans
notre pays et il confortera notre
système par répartition fondée sur le
travail et l'activité au delà chacune et
chacun a pu le défendre lors de nos
travaux en commission son projet de
société je n'aime pas que ses échanges
et de rapports vont se poursuivre dans
les semaines qui viennent et nous irons
au bout de ces débats car c'est ce que
nous devons à tous nos concitoyens tous
nos concitoyennes chers collègues comme
bon nombre d'entre vous je suis attachée
à notre modèle de retraite mais j'ai
toujours eu conscience que dans son
fonctionnement actuel
ils n'étaient que l'ancrage définitif de
toutes les inégalités structurer notre
pays sans que personne ne s'en émeuve
réellement un système dans lequel la
pension moyen des femmes et 40 2%
inférieures à celles des hommes
un système dans lequel celui qui a fait
des études et une carrière linéaire
ascendante partout à la retraite avec
une pension élevé quand celui
ce qu'il a fait que peu d'études et a
connu une carrière hachée par la
retraite avec une pension de misère pour
quelques années de vie restante c'est
notre système un système aux 42 régime
devenu totalement illisible un système
qui pourrait être à peu près à
l'équilibré nous demande de réforme est
durement ces paramètres
tous les 4-5 ans un système dans lequel
la défiance des français envers leurs
institutions et eux mêmes ne cesse de
croître
il est devenu au fur et à mesure des
années injuste et déconnectée des
réalités de notre société
ce système vous même si nous y sommes
habitués mes chers collègues nous devons
nous ne devons plus accepter et nous
devons le changer bien entendu les
débats sont vifs
c'est normal il s'agit de notre modèle
social le système universel vise à
pérenniser notre système de retraite par
répartition qui repose sur la solidarité
intergénérationnelle en le rendant
démocratiquement plus lisible et plus
transparent en garantissant les mêmes
droits à tous nos concitoyens
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui ils
ne visent en aucun cas à préparer la
mise en place d'un système de retraite
par capitalisation
ce qui ne serait de toute manière
techniquement et budgétairement pas
faisable
il vise par ailleurs à renforcer la
solidité budgétaire de notre système de
retraite et à mettre fin au cycle
interminable des réformes paramétriques
que nous connaissons depuis 30 ans enfin
il ne vise pas à conforter la position
de celles et ceux qui ont le plus mais
bien au contraire un à réduire en
profondeur les inégalités de notre
société en permettant à tous nos
concitoyens d'accéder à l'intégralité de
leurs droits
le système universel de retraite nous
permettra de réduire les nombreux effets
antiredistributifs du système actuel de
mieux prendre en compte les aspirations
à la mobilité de nos concitoyens de
mieux prendre en compte la pénibilité de
certains métiers
la construction progressive des fins de
carrière la réduction des inégalités
entre les femmes et les hommes
nous l'assumons et je tiens ici à saluer
mes collègues de la majorité pour leur
travail sur ces mesures et tout
particulièrement nos deux responsables
du groupe la république en marche mais
d'un quatre îles fabre et monique les
monts
la création mes chers collègues la
création de notre nouveau système de
retraite demande par ailleurs la mise en
place d'une gouvernance paritaire elle
sera confiée aux partenaires sociaux
sous le contrôle du parlement la mise en
place de ce système demande aussi que
nous travaillons sur la période de
transition notre système actuel vers le
nouveau système
cette transition sera longue et
s'étalera sur plus de 15 ans nous devons
assumer expliquer ce choix responsable
sur ce point je me félicite d'ailleurs
de la solution de la clause dite à
l'italienne qui a été retenue par le
gouvernement
enfin notre nouveau système de retraite
demande la définition de règles
budgétaires claire qui garantissent
l'équilibré du système dans la durée ces
règles sont inscrites dans le projet de
loi organique que nous avons adoptée en
commission
je tiens d'ailleurs à préciser que la
loi organique inscrire également dans le
marbre le fait que la valeur du point ne
pourra pas baisser que les
parlementaires rentreront dans le
système dès le 1er janvier 2022
mes chers collègues notre pays à l'un
des modèles sociaux les plus solides du
monde mais nous pouvons encore
l'améliorer personnellement je me suis
engagé en politique dans notre pays
étaient habitués depuis trop longtemps à
certaines injustices et avait arrêté sa
quête d'émancipation et de progrès je me
suis engagé en politique car je ne
pouvais plus accepter la résignation de
notre société a le plus lutter contre
les inégalités dans le seul but de ne
pas perdurer certain ordre établi alors
oui ce projet est exigeant et difficile
mais nous devons aller au bout et même
s'il ne nous permet pas de réparer
toutes les inégalités notre société il
nous permet de reprendre enfin notre
marche vers l'universalité de droit vers
la construction d'une république plus
juste plus solidaire plus fédératrice et
plus fraternelle c'est ce que nous
devons à nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens
c'est ce que nous devons aux générations
qui nous succèderont je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à monsieur nicolas turquois
rapporteur de la commission spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres
madame la présidente de la commission
spéciale mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous
entamons aujourd'hui en séance publique
l'examen de la réforme la plus
structurante du quinquennat qui
concrétise l'engagement pris devant les
français d'un système universel par
répartition
loin de renier les principes fondateurs
de notre sécurité sociale posée par
pierre laroque et ambroise croizat au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondiale
nous portons aux efforts cet héritage en
partage et prophétise ont enfin 70 ans
plus tard
l'ambition originelle de dépassement des
logiques professionnels et corporatistes
avant d'entrer dans le détail de cette
réforme
j'aimerais souligner l'ampleur des
débats en commission spéciale loin des
mauvais procès des présentations un
sincère qui circulent par le truchement
des réseaux sociaux il est toujours plus
facile de déformer une idée en 140
signes que de faire l'effort d'une
pensée construite et argumentée
il est toujours moins exigeants
d'adopter une posture démagogique que de
débattre projet contre projet à ce titre
l'obstruction assumées du groupe la
france insoumise a contrasté en
commission avec la défense de projets
solidement construit et argumentée par
d'autres groupes d'opposition
je la regrette même si elle n'a pas
empêché des échanges nourris avec
l'ensemble des commissaires sur le fond
le titre premier du projet de loi dont
j'ai l'honneur d'être le rapporteur a bu
chacun de ces alinéas analysé contesté
expliqué je tiens ici à remercier la
présidente de la commission spéciale
chère brigitte bourguignon pour la
qualité de nos débats qui font l'honneur
du travail parlementaire
ces débats en commission m'ont permis de
constater un double paradoxe
premier paradoxe nous nous accordons sur
ses bancs sur les imperfections et les
fragilités du système actuel
et pourtant toutes les mesures que nous
proposons pour les corriger ont fait
l'objet d'amendements de suppression
concrétiser la garantie d'une retraite
minimale à 1000 euros promise depuis
2003 jamais mis en oeuvre dans nos
prédécesseurs vous supprimez mettre un
terme à trente années d'indexation des
droits sur l'inflation retenant une
règle de revalorisation plus dynamiques
sur les revenus d'activité
vous supprimez aussi attribuer des
points dès le premier enfant et ne plus
imposer aux femmes d'attendre 67 ans
pour échapper au double malus vous
supprimez encore élargir la pénibilité à
l'ensemble des assurés
quel que soit leur statut et favoriser
la prise en compte des accidents de
parcours et des carrières heurtées
vous supprimez toujours second paradoxe
l'universalité du futur système irait à
la fois trop loin et pas assez loin au
sein des mêmes groupes les amendements
proposent à la fois d'appliquer les
mêmes règles pour tous et de prendre en
compte les situations individuelles
il propose à la fois d'intégrer
l'ensemble des professions dans le
système et de laisser en dehors par
exemple les marins les avocats il
propose à la fois d'abaisser la
couverture à un plafond de la sécurité
sociale et de l'étendre à 8
il propose à la fois de s'astreindre au
redressement des comptes sociaux est
d'engager plusieurs milliards d'euros
pour valoriser les revaloriser les
retraites
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir mais
notre choix est clair un système
universel 5 régime d'affiliation et une
pluralité de caisse pour prendre en
compte les spécificités professionnelles
à l'heure d'entamer nos débats en séance
publique
je suis heureux de porter à cette
tribune les choix politiques sur
lesquels les français nous ont accordé
leur confiance en 2017 à l'iniquité des
règles autres régimes vestiges d'un
autre temps nous préférons la
suppression progressive des régimes
spéciaux et l'accompagnement des
mobilités professionnelles aux trente
années d'indexation des droits sur la
place l'inflation nous préférons la
revalorisation des valeurs du point sur
les revenus d'activité
un système fragile financièrement
porteurs de déficit chronique
nous préférons la responsabilité
financière dans le respect d'une règle
d'or
pour ma part je ne comptait que je ne
conteste ni la complexité du système de
retraite ni l'ampleur de la
transformation que nous proposons nous
ne pouvons désormais plus regarder
ailleurs en feignant de ne pas prendre
en compte que le système actuel
alimentent la méfiance entretien de
nombreuses inégalités
c'est donc avec responsabilité avec une
responsabilité chevillée au corps que
j'ai défendrai ce texte pour expliquer
clarifier éclairer cette responsabilité
qui donne tout son sens au débat
parlementaire en démocratie en
démocratie
cette responsabilité qui nous oblige
devant nos concitoyens qu'attendent de
nous justice équité cette responsabilité
qui accompagnait déjà antoine de
saint-exupéry dans son voyage dans le
transsibérien si bien raconter dans le
terre des hommes et qui fine qui
finissaient par s'est sentie remportant
sa pierre que l'on contribue à bâtir le
monde je vous en remercie merci monsieur
le rapporteur la parole et à monsieur
jacques maire rapporteur de la
commission spéciale
[Applaudissements]
le sport
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres
madame la présidente de la commission
spéciale mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues je
commencerai par évoquer un regret la
commission spéciale n'a pu aller au
terme de ses travaux
vous savez pourquoi elle a pu examiner
uniquement quatre des articles du titre
2 c'est donc ma perception brut du titre
2 que je vais vous présenter ce titre
qui vise à garantir l'équité et la
liberté dans le choix du départ à la
retraite la liberté tout d'abord c'est
une meilleure transition entre
l'activité professionnelle et la
retraite
le projet développe la retraite
progressive pour ceux qui souhaite
ralentir le rythme sont baisser leur
niveau de vie il offre également des
droits nouveaux à ceux qui ont fait le
choix de reprendre une activité après
leur départ à la retraite en leur
permettant de cotiser et de gagner des
points
il met fin ainsi à l'injustice de ceux
qui cotisent sans aucun droit
eh bien ces droits ils permettront d'
adoucir les transitions entre l'activité
et la retraite
je sais qu'elle réponde à une demande
forte des français
et cette demande elle nous a été porté
directement par les partenaires sociaux
deux amendements apportés adopté par la
commission spéciale à l'initiative de
nos collègues catherine fabre et thierry
michel améliorent déjà l'information sur
le droit à ces dispositifs
ces dispositifs ils ont un objectif
celui d'améliorer durablement l'emploi
des travailleurs expérimentés mais la
liberté c'est aussi donner à chacun la
possibilité de partir à l'âge de la
retraite à l'âge qu'il souhaite en toute
connaissance de cause et c'est pourquoi
nous avons maintenu l'âge d'ouverture du
droit à la retraite à 62 ans alors que
d'autres groupes dans cette assemblée le
porterai volontiers et n'en font pas
état d'âme à 64 ans ou à 65 ans
l'équité ensuite les quitter parce que
nous reconnaissons que des situations de
handicap de carrières longues ou des
validité peuvent effectivement justifier
un départ anticipé à la retraite
ces dispositifs existent aujourd'hui
pour certains régimes seulement ils
s'appliqueront demain à tous les
français à tous les français y compris
les fonctionnaires les salariés des
régimes spéciaux mais aussi les
agriculteurs ou les indépendants
venons en maintenant aux missions
régaliennes dangereuse ce sont les
policiers les surveillants
pénitentiaires les douaniers ou encore
les sapeurs pompiers professionnels
vous connaissez parfaitement leur
engagement et les risques qu'ils courent
ainsi leurs compensations sont reconnus
dans le projet de loi de même que leurs
conditions de départ anticipé
quant aux militaires puisque vous me
invité laurent je n'ai pas la retraite
mais la deuxième carrière
la grande majorité des militaires ne
doit pas s'éterniser dans une armée
actifs qui doit rester jeune et la
condition militaire est totalement
reconnue dans ce projet de loi et elle
est même améliorée pour les hommes du
rang j'en viens au transition
l'harmonisation des droits ne doit pas
être brutal bien au contraire
le projet de loi préserve les droits
acquis pour les fonctionnaires qui
demain ne feront plus partie des
catégories actives
il aménage des transitions longue et la
montée en charge des dispositifs
universel de prise en compte de la
pénibilité pour les en faire bénéficier
en tant que rapporteur j'ai consulté les
partenaires sociaux sans filtre ni
langue de bois
les concertations menées avec le
gouvernement et qui ont été rappelés par
le ministre pietra cf qui ont abouti à
enrichir le dispositif
ces derniers jours sur de nombreux
besoins point sur les transitions sur la
pénibilité ou encore sur les retraites
progressives et bien nous serons avec le
gouvernement les garants de ces avancées
et nous les traduirons scrupuleusement
dans le texte par amendement mais
l'accord
c'est pas fait surtout il reste un point
d'achoppement sur lequel je voudrais
terminer la pénibilité notamment pour
les quatre facteurs de risque chimique
et ergonomique les charges lourdes
les postures pénibles et les vibrations
mécaniques ces titres n'ouvre pas de
droit au titre du compte professionnel
de prévention
même si je note un point très positif de
ces derniers jours la création d'un
congé de conversion pour ces risques la
négociation n'est donc pas terminée sur
ces sujets elle doit apporter des
garanties complémentaires non seulement
en termes de prévention mais également
en terme de réparation et donc de départ
anticipé il parvenir suppose que chacun
joue le jeu d'abord dans le cadre de la
concertation sociale en cours et nous ne
voulons pas ici court circuiter les
partenaires sociaux mais nous appelons
fortement à ce que la concertation
aboutisse j'ai déposé un amendement en
ce sens pour annoncer clairement nos
intentions
les partenaires fsa définir au niveau de
la branche d'exposition aux facteurs de
pénibilité
absolument si le problème n'est pas
résolu nous prendrons nos
responsabilités en seconde lecture et
nous proposerons un dispositif à
opérationnel en conclusion chers
collègues le système de retraite
universel offre des réponses très
concrètes aux questions que se posent
les français sur les carrières longues
la pénibilité des régimes spéciaux les
fonctions publiques
le débat qui s'ouvre va nous permettre
de les examiner
enfin devant tous les français je vous
remercie merci la parole à madame
corinne vignand rapporteur de la
commission spéciale
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
messieurs les ministres madame la
présidente de la commission spéciale
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues je regrette vivement
que la commission spéciale est
interrompu ses travaux avant d'arriver à
l'examen du titre iii qui traite
spécifiquement des mécanismes de
solidarité du projet de loi
l'esprit de justice sociale qui allume
la réforme et en particulier dans ce
titre aurait mérité en effet des
échanges de fond sur chacune des mesures
proposées
mais le temps du débat viendra et je
suis impatiente de défendre devant vous
les mesures d'équité qui sont
développées j'ai un que nous évoquions
en particulier l'ensemble des nouveaux
droits offerts aux femmes qui sont les
vrais gagnante de ce système universel
si le facile s'il ne fallait choisir que
quelques mesures emblématiques de cette
redistribution bénéfice des femmes je
citerai un la garantie d'une retraite
minimale à 85% du smic
puisque deux tiers des bénéficiaires du
minimum de pension sont des femmes les
majorations de pension pour enfants qui
sont attribués dès le premier enfant et
non à compter du troisième comme
aujourd'hui l'attribution de points
supplémentaires pour les aidants
familiaux puisque chacun sait que ce
sont très majoritairement des femmes qui
sacrifient leur carrière professionnelle
pour veiller à leurs proches souffrent
handicapées ou en fin de vie je veux
saluer à ce titre les avancées que
constitue l'attribution de points aux
parents d'enfants dans le taux
d'incapacité est supérieure à 50 %
contre 80 % aujourd'hui
j'ai hâte ensuite que nous abordions les
mesures du titre iii qui gagnent grands
qui vont garantir un niveau de vie
décent à tous les retraités du système
universel
en effet je ne peux que me réjouir que
le projet de loi concrétise enfin
l'engagement qui
avait été votée dans cet hémicycle est à
peu près 20 ans visant à garantir une
pension de 85% du smic net pour
l'ensemble des assurés qui ont effectué
une carrière complète
une telle mesure de justice est attendue
en particulier par les exploitants
agricoles et les travailleurs
indépendants dont les pensions annuelles
et moyennes sont plus basses que le
reste des travailleurs
c'est pourquoi sans attendre nous leur
offrirons des 2022
une pension minimale de 1000 euros pour
une carrière complète le système
universel garantira par ailleurs une
meilleure prise en compte des aléas de
la vie grâce à l'attribution de points
de solidarité dès le premier jour d'une
interruption de travail liées au chômage
à la maladie à la maternité et à la
paternité puisque c'est une mesure
inédite proposée dans la loi j'ai
également hâte que nous puissions
échanger sur les droits familiaux et
conjugaux qui sont au coeur des
dispositifs de redistribution du système
de retraites
le système universel accordera en effet
des droits plus juste à toutes les
familles quelle que soit leur
configuration les familles modestes ne
seront pas oubliés puisque les points
leur seront attribués dès lors qu'un
parent réduit ou interrompt son activité
professionnelle pour se consacrer à
l'éducation de ses enfants
je suis en outre certaines que nos
débats permettront d'enrichir chacune de
ces mesures pour tenir compte des
familles monoparentales ou des familles
touchées par le handicap sur la
réversion je ne peux que saluer le choix
qui a été retenu de calculer leur
version par rapport au niveau de vie du
couple de mettre fin aux traits système
de calcul existants et de permettre
d'augmenter la pension des conjoints
survivants aux revenus les plus modestes
j'ai un enfin d'échanger avec vous sur
les mesures relatives aux jeunes ainsi
les périodes d'apprentissage de service
civique
où l'exercice d'un sport de haut niveau
donnera lieu à l'attribution de points
de solidarité pour ne pas pénaliser les
jeunes qui ont fait le choix de
consacrer leur vie aux autres ou étudier
autrement toutes ces mesures
contribueront à définir un système de
retraites plus juste plus équitable qui
fait fi des statuts pour accorder les
mêmes droits à tous les assurés
confronté aux mêmes aléas de la vie je
forme le voeu mesdames et messieurs que
nos débats soient riches et constructifs
que ses exams ans et solidaire soit mise
à jour pour permettre à nos concitoyens
d'évaluer ses progrès sociaux et
d'aborder le temps de la retraite avec
beaucoup plus de sérénité
je vous remercie merci madame la
rapporteure
la parole est à mme carole dérangeant
rapporteur de la commission spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission spéciale
madame et messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues notre modèle social est
un bien commun précieux dont les
générations actuelles ont hérité et
qu'elles ont pour responsabilité de
protéger des l'ordonance du 4 octobre
les pères fondateurs de la sécurité
sociale ont assigné à la sécurité
sociale une mission essentielle est
ambitieuse celle de garantir à chaque
assuré une couverture solidaire des
risques sociaux chacun de nous sur ces
bancs est attaché à ce patrimoine légué
par 70 ans de construction sociale
piliers du pacte républicain et fierté
de notre nation ce patrimoine en commun
et pourtant fragilisé en matière de
retraite
fragilisé par la confiance que lui
accordent les jeunes générations souvent
convaincus qu elles ne bénéficieront pas
du système par répartition
fragilisé par trente années de
déséquilibres financiers auxquels les
réformes successives knockin également
est temporairement répondu fragilisé par
un foisonnement de règles
d'institutions qui nourrissent la
complexité du système et le non recours
au droit
la nouvelle gouvernance du système de
retraites qu'il me revient de rapporter
au titre iv apporte une réponse claire
et efficace à ces différentes fragilité
en créant la caisse nationale de
retraite universel
nous faisons ce choix de l'intégration
de l'ensemble des assurés dans un
système commun qui garantira lisibilité
et équité pour qu'une justice sociale
soit une réalité effective de notre
système de retraite
en s'appuyant sur les caisses de
retraite actuel pour construire le
système de demain nous affirmons notre
confiance dans les interlocuteurs
habituels des assurés qui allie
expérience et proximité surtout en
confiant le conseil d'administration aux
partenaires sociaux nous servir nous
affirmons haut et fort notre attachement
au paritarisme loin du mauvais procès en
étatisation aussi infondées qu'un
sincères les débats en séance publique
seront l'occasion d'aborder pour la
première fois dans la discussion
parlementaire l'ensemble de ces enjeux
de gouvernance et de pilotage pour la
première fois puisque la pratique de
l'obstruction parlementaire a
malheureusement empêché d'atteindre
l'examen du titre iv en commission
contrastant avec les fortes attentes
qu'il suscite auprès des partenaires
sociaux et de nos concitoyens il est
temps enfin d'aborder le détail de cette
nouvelle gouvernance qui fait l'objet
d'un grand nombre d'amendements
consacrée à l'avenir institutionnel de
nos retraites
nos débats seront d'ailleurs
indispensable pour dissiper les
ambiguïtés alimenté plus ou moins
sincèrement par des arguments de tous
bords aucune ambiguïté du côté de la
coordination entre les différentes
instances
la procédure de conventionnement
permettra à la seine et rue d'assurer
une couverture et une qualité de service
homogène sur l'ensemble du territoire
aucune ambiguïté non plus concernant
l'avenir des carsat
je soutiendrai le maintien de leur
personnalité morale et la garantie du
maintien de l'ensemble des effectifs
aucune ambiguïté enfin concernant la
place du parlement
plusieurs amendements viendront garantir
son information et son inscription à
part entière dans le nouveau pilotage
financier
à ce titre il m'a paru plus utile de
porter des amendements replaçant le
parlement au coeur de cette nouvelle
gouvernance
ce que s'enfermer dans une opposition
stérile entre démocratie sociale et
démocratie parlementaire
évidemment cette gouvernance ne pourra
être construite que progressivement en
s'installant dans le temps long en
première année de préfiguration
succédera l'installation des déserts des
nouvelles instances
au delà la cnr et au fonds de solidarité
vieillesse universel de fonds de réserve
universel et comité d'expertisé
indépendant des retraites en constituant
autant d'illustrations qui permettront
de donner un nouveau souffle au système
de retraite du 21e siècle au moment
d'entamer la construction de cette
nouvelle gouvernance
je m'attacherai à replacer nos travaux
dans cette perspective du temps long
trop souvent méconnus ou oubliés par le
passé les mots de simone veil prononcé
le 5 octobre 2005 lors de l'ouverture du
colloque du 60e anniversaire de la
sécurité sociale peuvent aujourd'hui
nous guider et résonner dans cet
hémicycle comme une injonction à prendre
nos responsabilités pour construire
l'avenir de notre système de retraite
pour qu'ils soient plus justes et
équilibrées plus solide
l'histoire de notre protection sociale
est faite de constructions successives
de la volonté d'hommes et de femmes de
construire ensemble cette solidarité que
nous avons reçue en héritage
c'était nous qu'il appartient désormais
de porter une reconstruction solidaire
et universelle
je vous remercie merci madame laura
porter la parole d'un monsieur paul
christophe rapporteur de la commission
spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission spéciale
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues
rien ne sert de courir il faut partir à
point en ouvrant ainsi sa célèbre fable
la fontaine nous invitait à méditer une
leçon des plus profondes atteindre le
but qu'on s'est fixés nécessite tout à
la fois de la préparation de la
détermination et du temps la préparation
c'est la concertation qui a eu lieu
pendant deux ans ce sont les travaux
menés par le gouvernement ou encore une
consultation citoyenne que le conseil
d'état qualifie lui-même de profond
c'est dur approfondie soulignant la
procédure originale de participation
citoyenne organisée la préparation c'est
aussi notre travail de parlementaire
alors que nous disposons des
orientations générales depuis presque
six mois à travers le rapport remis en
juillet au gouvernement du cap fixé par
le premier ministre le 5 décembre
dernier et de l'avant projet de loi
depuis plusieurs semaines la
détermination nous l'avons montré en
commission et la montrerons encore dans
cet hémicycle les quatre premiers titres
permettent de définir un cadre un
objectif une cible pour réformer en
profondeur un système à bout de souffle
enfin le temps nous allons le prendre
pour assurer des transitions adapté et
concertée vers le système que nous
voulons c'est tout l'objet de ce titre 5
que j'ai l'honneur de rapporter prendre
le temps c'est tout d'abord garantir à
nos concitoyens la conservation pleine
et entière des droits constitués dans
l'ancien système
si le principe est portée sans ambiguïté
par l'habilitation prévu à l'article 61
le premier ministre a précisé la semaine
dernière la méthode
je me réjouis pour ma part du choix du
gouvernement d'une clause dite à
l'italienne particulièrement protectrice
des assurés les droits seront pris en
compte
regard de l'ensemble de la carrière
effectuée dans l'ancien comme dans le
nouveau système de retraite
prendre le temps c'est aussi tenir
compte du changement très profond que
nous proposons dans l' architecture
notre système de retraite
les frontières entre régimes de base et
complémentaires doivent ainsi progresser
et s'estomper c'est le temps de
l'article 62 qui met fin aux
affiliations légalement obligatoire à
ces régimes tout en aménageant des
espaces d'information de dialogue de
contractualisation pour que ces
évolutions se déroulent dans les
meilleures conditions
il est bon de rappeler que le futur
système universel s'appuiera très
largement sur le savoir faire des femmes
et des hommes qui travaillent dans ces
régimes complémentaires et que le projet
de loi n'entend pas se passer de ce qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui prendre le temps
c'est aussi se donner un calendrier
clair et adapté des transitions longues
sont prévues sur de nombreux sujets par
le texte
mes collègues rapporteur l'ont souvent
évoqués en commission
pour ma part j'insisterai sur trois
rendez-vous important que fixe
d'articles 63 après l'adoption de la loi
que nous examinons le 1er décembre 2020
verra la mise en place d'une gouvernance
préfiguratrice chargé de préparer puis
de mettre en oeuvre la réforme le 1er
janvier 2022 verra l'entrée dans le
système des premiers assuré avec la mise
en oeuvre de l'ensemble des outils que
nous aurons voté
enfin le 1er janvier 2000 25 actera la
généralisation du système est le point
de départ des transitions que nous avons
prévu sur les droits comme sur les
cotisations prendre le temps toujours
c'est tenir compte de la spécificité de
la diversité de nos territoires
c'est ainsi que l'article 64 prévoit
l'adaptation du système universel aux
caractéristiques et contraintes
particulières de départements et
territoires d'outre-mer
ces mesures seront bien évidemment
concerter avec les premiers concernés
afin de concilier la pleine application
du système universel sur l'ensemble du
territoire et les nécessaires
spécificité à prendre en compte dans son
application
enfin prendre le temps c'est aussi
assumer que le chantier suffisamment
ambitieux pour mériter toute notre
attention
quitte à repousser à plus tard des
réflexions sur des sujets sans lien avec
le projet sur l'épargné des français
je ne suis pas dupe de
l'instrumentalisation qui est faite de
l'article 65 par certaines oppositions
ces dernières oublie un peu vite que
l'épargné retraite n'a pas été créée par
le gouvernement
et quelle est la réalité quotidienne de
nombreux français depuis longtemps y
compris dans la fonction publique ou
encore au profit des salariés de la
banque de france
avoir voulu les améliorer en les rendant
plus simple plus lisible plus ouvertes
ou plus avantageuse n'a rien d'un digne
ni deux on peut même si ces solutions ne
remplaceront jamais un solide régime par
répartition
toutefois le rapporteur général et
moi-même considérons que ce texte n'est
pas le bon véhicule pratique et ses
avancées issues de la loi pacte qui
mérite contenus dans nature mais aussi
précisément de le rapport un débat
spécifique
c'est pourquoi nous proposerons la
suppression de cet article ce
renforcement passe par une assise
démographique plus solide grâce à
l'universalité par l'intégration trop
rarement sous gagnés en son sein des
régimes qui fonctionne aujourd'hui par
capitalisation
ce n'est pas le temps qui manque si nous
qui nous manquons avertissez paul
claudel nous avons reçu ce message cinq
sur cinq
s'agissant d'une réforme qui voit loin
elle a donc non seulement par le
diagnostic de portons sur les défauts du
système actuel une raison d'être et un
sens par le système que nous proposons
un cap et une cohérence
elle a aussi par le souci de changer
dans le respect du réel un rythme et un
chemin je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole et de madame sandra moteur
rapporteur de la commission spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission spéciale
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues les occasions que nous avons
en tant que parlementaire de nous
positionner sur des choix qui engagent
le pays pendant des décennies ne sont
pas si nombreuses or avec ces deux
projets de loi relatif à la création
d'un système universel de retraite
nous y sommes pleinement mettant à
porter que du projet de loi organique
je ne dirai pas combien l'universalité
et le projet originel de la sécurité
sociale je ne dirais pas que la
convergence entre les régimes qui
semblent inatteignables à certains
aujourd'hui et le chemin suivi par
toutes les réformes conduites ces
dernières années par des majorités très
différentes
je ne dirais pas non plus combien je
trouve étrange leurs proches qui nous
est fait de parachever ce mouvement
historique profond en prévoyant les
conditions dans lesquelles la protection
sociale potes et doit surmonter les
corporatismes qui l'ont vu naître et
mettre en oeuvre l'idéal d'égalité qui
est sa véritable raison d'être
je rappellerai simplement qu'un tel
projet croiser nécessairement une
réflexion institutionnelle
celle qui est porté par ce projet de loi
organique que j'ai l'honneur de
rapporter à quad et à quoi tient cette
réflexion en trois points essentiels à
mon sens pour assurer la pérennité de
notre système de retraite par
répartition
il convient d'abord d'engager notre
responsabilité dans la manière dont nous
devons financer
or je n'ai entendu en commission aucun
groupe
aucune voix défendre un financement
durable par l'endettement
c'est pourtant ce que nous avons fait
collectivement depuis des années chacun
comprend ici surtout c'est bon j'en suis
sûr que faire payer les pensions du jour
par la génération du lendemain est une
profonde injustice
cette injustice jette discrédit sur un
système par répartition notamment chez
les plus jeunes
alors que la confiance est la condition
de sa survie chacun comprend ici
également que chaque euro qui finance
des charges d'intérêts est perdu pour la
redistribution
aussi il me semble que le principe de l'
équilibre financier est beaucoup plus
consensuel dans cet hémicycle que
d'aucuns essayent de le faire croire kit
admettre un désaccord sur le moyen d'y
parvenir
aussi nous souhaitons que les
législateurs organique fasse respecter
deux règles simples la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale devra
proposer une trajectoire équilibrée du
système de retraite sur cinq ans si
cette dette cumulée des passes
l'équivalent de 10 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui
cette même loi de financement devra
prévoir d'arrêter cet effet boule de
neige et de prévoir les conditions de sa
réduction
j'ai bien conscience que le souci d
équilibre qui caractérise le fond comme
la forme de cette proposition ne
satisfera ni les adeptes de la rigueur
pour la rigueur ni ceux qui se préparent
sans toujours se l'avouer alain
soutenabilité de leurs propositions
j'assume ce double désaccord car il est
la démonstration même du caractère
raisonnable de la démarche
cependant il manquait à ce cadre
inavouables manquons sensuelle une autre
règle d'or respectées par toutes les
majorités et que la nôtre souhaite voir
gravé dans le marbre organique après
l'avoir fait figurer dans la loi dans le
système universel
la valeur des pensions ne baissera pas
et les valeurs du point ne pourront être
revalorisées en dessous de l'inflation
évidemment nous souhaitons faire bien
mieux en injection les pensions sur les
prix et la revalorisation du point sur
les revenus
pour cela il nous a semblé sous
l'impulsion de celui qui siège
aujourd'hui un mètre plus à gauche qui
hier plus sur d'élever ses planchers
jusqu'au niveau organique où il sera
plus difficile à des majorités moins
scrupuleuses d'y porter attentes
deuxième point essentiel du cadre
institutionnel que nous voulons donner
un lieu de débat annuel devant la
représentation nationale sur nos
politiques de retraite loin de
l'étatisation décrite parfois
l'intégration au sein de nos débats de
automne des retraites complémentaires
étaient une évolution indispensable des
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale dans la perspective d'un système
largement unifiée cet élargissement du
champ de la délibération démocratique
dès 2022 est un préalable précieux 100
milliards d'euros de dépenses échappé à
notre information et à notre contrôle
s'agissant pourtant de régimes de
retraite rendue obligatoire par la loi
depuis 1972 le paritarisme n'en
souffrira pas bien au contraire mais je
crois surtout en tant que parlementaire
que nous avons une valeur ajoutée à
apporter
plutôt que de laisser se jouer sans rien
dire le face à face entre l'exécutif et
les organes paritaires les effets
bénéfiques de cette évolution dépendront
largement de l'amélioration des
conditions de l'examen de la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale cela
semble va sans dire mais j'ai bon espoir
que nous ayons avancés d'ici là sur la
base des travaux du haut conseil
je finirai simplement monsieur le
président par une citation de winston
churchill construire peut-être le fruit
d'un travail long et acharné détruire
peut être l'oeuvre d'une seule journée
gageons que nous saurons d'ici ici
construire ensemble pour les générations
du futur tu vous remercie merci madame
le rapporteur
la parole est à madame brigitte
bourguignon présidente de la commission
spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues il est rare qu'une
commission spéciale ou non soit amené à
prendre acte de ce qu'elle n'a pu
totalement achevé ses travaux en temps
utile non sans regrets c'est ce que j'ai
proposé à la commission de faire mardi
dernier lorsqu'il est apparu qu'elle ne
serait pas en mesure d'achever l'examen
du projet de loi ordinaire
mercredi en revanche la commission a
demandé à adopter le projet de loi
organique que notre assemblée examinera
donc dans le texte de la commission
laissez moi vous dire ma fierté d'avoir
été comme beaucoup d'entre vous partie
prenante de ce moment de démocratie
parlementaire
ces choses assez aisé à faire d'un
simple point de vue quantitatif
la commission spéciale s'est réuni à 27
reprises durant plus de 90 heures elle a
été saisie de 22 mille six cent
cinquante huit amendements en a examiné
6059 la commission et donc beaucoup
travaillé mais surtout elle a bien
travaillé ce travail ne restera pas
lettre morte
elle a adopté 21 amendement ils ont été
déposés par les rapporteurs et seront
examinés en séance publique
je veux rendre hommage à notre
rapporteur général et à nos rapporteur
qui ont apporté une contribution
essentielle aux débats je veux bien sûr
avoir un mot plus personnel pour olivier
ferrand à qui j'adresse mes chaleureuses
félicitations et souhaite pleine
réussite
je remercie laurent pietrasinski de sa
présence constante pendant ces dix
journées je remercie aussi l'ensemble
des membres de la commission spéciale et
au delà qui ont pris part à la
discussion
mes chers collègues beaucoup a été dit
sur la stratégie parlementaire de tel ou
tel groupe que l'on a pu entendre
qualifié d' obstruction pour ma part je
n'ai jamais employé ce mot parce que je
crois au parlement et au travail en
commission parce que je crois en la
fonction tribunitienne
du travail parlementaire parce que je
crois que notre assemblée
quand elle s'écoute jouent un rôle
fondamental celui de la confrontation
des idées parce que je crois en tout
cela le débat qui s'est tenu a été utile
à la démocratie précisément parce que le
confrontation politique a eu lieu va
leur contre-valeur idées contre idées
projet contre projet alors il y a pu
avoir quelques moments des excès de
ferveur mais le jour où il n'y a plus
ses excès ses éclats de voix
il n'y a plus de parlement je préfère
retenir le feuilleton de marie
l'infirmière n'est ce pas madame fiat
face aux véritables égouts à pulsions
qui se sont installés sur les réseaux
sociaux ou dans d'autres formes
d'expression il y a un parlement et il
permet à toutes les idées d'être
représentée à toutes les expressions d'y
être d'y être donné place maintenant
donc au travail en séance
gage à celui ci d'affiner ce texte de
l'améliorer gageons aussi à la
démocratie sociale de faire son oeuvre
pendant que nous faisons la loi les
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre de la
conférence sur l' équilibre et le
financement des retraites cherche un
compromis pour garantir le financement
de notre service de notre système de
retraite à la française
ce dialogue entre démocratie
représentative et démocratie sociale qui
donne au parlement le dernier mot est de
bonne politique
c'est d'une certaine manière une étape
de plus dans l' équilibre démocratique
que nous appelons de nos voeux
alors bon débat à tous et vive
l'assemblée nationale je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente
j'ai reçu j'ai reçu de monsieur andré
chassaigne des membres du groupe de la
gauche démocrate et républicaine
une motion de rejet préalable déposé en
application de l'article 91 alinéa 5 du
règlement sur le projet de loi ordinaire
instituant un système universel de
retraite la parole de monsieur pierre
dharréville
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres chères et chers collègues
c'est un film en avaient ils cochent
toutes les cases à tel point qu'on ne
sait par où commencer
le scénario est poussif la fable
alambiqué le sujet maltraiter les plans
répétitif
les dialogues font le metteur en scène
autoritaire la photo date et les
cadrages et 3 le casting illégal à tel
point que les acteurs quittent le
plateau sans crier gare ce projet est
monstrueux et le monstre vous échappe
et vous avez dès maintenant la
possibilité salutaire que dis-je la
possibilité le pouvoir est sans aucun
doute le devoir de mettre fin à ce
cauchemar à ce supplice à cette lourde
faute
l'enjeu est essentiel
le droit à la retraite et c'est vrai
qu'avoir ainsi le gouvernement y mettre
les pieds on est saisi d'un sentiment de
profanation la situation actuelle nan
mais connaît les défauts et plutôt que
les logiques de rétractation qui ont
prévalu ces derniers temps il est urgent
de se remettre dans une démarche
d'édification mais quand on voit un
nouvel arrivant se présenter comme celui
qui vient accomplir les écritures et
déclaré vouloir raser la maison commune
pour en construire une autre à sa main
on s'inquiète on s'inquiète d'autant
plus que voilà si longtemps que les
marchands veulent entrer dans le temple
mais nous tenons cependant sous droits à
la retraite pour autre chose que pour un
symbole sacré c'est un marqueur concrets
de civilisation parce qu'il faut
travailler pour vivre
qu'advient-il quand on est empêché de
travailler c'est à cette question
d'abord qu'on a tenté de répondre et
puis on s'est attelé à faire comme le
dira croisa que la retraite ne soit plus
l'antichambre de la mort mais une
nouvelle étape de la vie
ainsi la retraite est elle un droit
patiemment édifié au cours du siècle
passé et hélas savamment t bréchet dans
les décennies écoulées
un droit que l'on créé par le travail et
qui se partagent par delà les
générations
un droit qui fait partie intégrante du
salaire et qui se traduit par un salaire
continué un droit qui permet d'être
libérée du travail prescrit
quand on y attend consacré dans la force
de
je ce droit s'inscrit dans la
philosophie de la sécurité sociale qui
entend socialiser et sanctuary zay la
part des richesses produites suffisante
à garantir une assurance contre les
aléas de l'existence
tout au long de la vie c'est tout un
monde que l'on gagne pour les autres et
pour soi même voilà l'un des traits de
l'émancipation par le travail
c'est ainsi seulement en libérant les
travailleurs de l' obsession permanente
de la misère qu'on permettra à tous les
hommes et à toutes les femmes de
développer pleinement leurs possibilités
leur personnalité ainsi par les embrasse
croizat à cette tribune
le 8 août 1946 lui et les autres dont
certains trahissent la mémoire et des
intentions parce qu'il leur donne
mauvaise conscience de chacun selon ses
moyens à chacun selon ses besoins
l'ambition à une autre figure que le
slogan chaque euro cotisé doit donner
les mêmes droits qui sous les apparences
de l'égalité tu cultives chacun pour soi
une maxime ni désirable ni applicable
tant nos parcours peuvent être
différents d'un bout à l'autre de
l'existence voilà pourquoi si l'on veut
engager une réforme d'une telle portée
telluriques
il vaut mieux y avoir bien réfléchi y
avoir bien travaillé et avoir
suffisamment rassemblé cher des chers
collègues auriez tort de prendre cette
demande de rejet du texte pour une
formalité
croyez bien que je meurs d'envié de
demander au gouvernement
qu'est ce que vous ne comprenez pas dans
le mot retraite qu'est ce que vous ne
comprenez pas dans le mot retrait mais
c'est d'abord à vous que je veux
principalement m'adresser parce que la
situation est grave et je suis certain
que nombre d'entre vous se disent tout
bas que les conditions ne sont
assurément pas réunies pour acter un
bouleversement complet de notre droit à
la retraite alors le geste salutaire
dont le gouvernement n'a pas eu la
lucidité ni le courage le parlement peut
désormais le faire un geste de sursaut
de respect de la démocratie et
finalement de soi même c'est plus que
jamais le moment
depuis le début ses promoteurs voudrait
torpillé leur oeuvre et la rendre un
constitutionnel qui ne s'y prendrait pas
autrement
et en arrivant devant nous aujourd'hui
une chose est désormais établi le texte
n'est pas prêt il est complètement
bilbocks il est en papier mâché
je récapitule
à l'économie car les faits sont
accablants pendant deux ans à la suite
d'une idée de campagne plus ou moins
claires et plus ou moins reprises par
les candidats aux législatives un haut
commissaire a animé des cafés débats et
mener quelques opérations de com visant
à dénigrer le système actuel dans le but
de préparer l'opinion faisant l'objet de
fuites contradictoires plusieurs fois
annoncée elle devait finalement venir
l'été prochain mais nous y voici
dès l'hiver parce que le gouvernement a
tenté un coup tactique foireux la
concertation sociale a été une aimable
farce
personne n'était demandeur et personne
n'a été écouté le dessaisissement des
organisations syndicales dont le rôle
est actuellement centrale a été
appliquée avant l'heure et elles n'ont
en réalité jamais disposé du texte sans
parler des concertations périphériques
décoratives
voici les assurés expulsé flagrant
défaut de dialogue social
le premier ministre a présenté la
réforme dans un discours qui a provoqué
la colère pour diviser les générations
il annoncé une entrée en vigueur à
partir de l'année 1975 accompagné d'un
âge pivot puis pour gagner du temps il
inventa la suspension provisoire de cet
article et une conférence de financement
se prolongeant au-delà de la première
lecture avec une épée de damoclès
au-dessus des têtes voici donc parlement
appelé à se prononcer sur un projet
provisoire à la main du gouvernement
dix jours plus tard le pilote de la
réforme démissionner notamment pour
n'avoir pas déclaré des activités et
pour de possibles conflits d'intérêts
laissant un texte inachevé et bardé de
29 ordonnance portant sur une
quarantaine de questions structurantes
le conseil d'état écrira que cela je
cite fait perdre la visibilité
d'ensemble qui est nécessaire à
l'appréciation des conséquences de la
réforme et partant de sa
constitutionnalité et de sa
conventionalité flagrant défaut de
précisions depuis le 5 décembre un
mouvement social d'une grande ampleur a
gagné le pays se traduisant par de
nombreux mouvements de grève et des
manifestations considérable tandis que
les enquêtes d'opinion ont montré un
soutien clair de la population et un
rejet massif de la réforme engagée le
gouvernement faisait le dos rond en
attendant que ça passe et espère est en
vain un retournement à la faveur des
fêtes et plus les choses avancent et
plus été mise en lumière les
conséquences pour de nombreuses
professions dans tous les secteurs
la société pour tenter de dégonfler la
colère était consenti quelques
exceptions souvent fait de faux
semblants qui sonnait comme autant
d'aveux de défaillance intrinsèque du
miraculeux système dans son obstination
paniquer le gouvernement des clashs ans
sans justification valable
la procédure accélérée réduisant au
maximum le travail parlementaire
flagrant défaut de démocratie
c'est dans ce cadre que le 24 janvier le
conseil d'état a rendu un avis cinglant
jugeant le texte avec une extrême
sévérité
critiquant la consultation factice de
certains organismes
il ne s'estimait pas lui-même à même de
mener sa mission je le cite avec la
sérénité et les délais de réflexion
nécessaire pour garantir au mieux la
sécurité juridique et de trouver cette
situation je le cite encore d'autant
plus regrettable que les projets de loi
procède à une réforme du système de
retraite inédite depuis 1945 est destiné
à transformer pour les décennies à venir
un système social qui constitue l'une
des composantes majeures du contrat
social pour lui
l'inconstitutionnalité est manifeste
concernant les promesses imprécise de
revalorisation pour les enseignants et
les chercheurs
sidérant bricolage flagrant délit d'un
préparation enfin le conseil d'état
remet vertement en cause la fiabilité de
l'étude d'impact jugée insuffisante et
lacunaire au point de rappeler que le
document d'impact doivent répondre aux
exigences générales d'objectivité et de
sincérité des travaux procédant à leur
élaboration
sa faiblesse est inversement
proportionnel à son volume notamment en
termes d'impacts économiques et sociaux
par exemple
considérant l'augmentation du nombre de
personnes plus de 65 ans de plus de 65
ans de 70% d'ici à 2070 ainsi que leur
faible taux d'emploi
le conseil d'état appelle le
gouvernement s'il veut jouer sur l'âge
de départ à taux plein en mesurer les
effets sur les comptes de l'assurance
chômage et les dépenses de minima
sociaux
une paille précisons que derrière les
chiffres il y à daisy et le gouvernement
brille par son incapacité à décrire les
droits des assurés
son étude comporte des bidouillages pour
présenter les choses sous un jour
avantageux par exemple
sur les 28 cas type de personne née en
1990 présenté 21 cas son annonce les
gagnants
en réalité 18 sur 28 sont perdants selon
le collectif no retraite.fr le
gouvernement il ya ajouté une
provocation en promettant une fois la
réforme votée un simulateur basé au
passage sur un système déjà existant
l'étude ne décrit pas mieux les
mécanismes de transition les zones
d'ombré sont partout flagrant défaut
d'information il s'avère de surcroît que
les maigres informations contenues dans
l'étude d'impact ne colle pas exactement
avec les annonces qui avaient été faites
on avait parlé d'un âge déquilibre à 64
ans pour la génération 75
en réalité le texte annonce plutôt 65
ans et un allongement à suivre au
passage on méconnaît les conventions
minimal de l'oit et en la matière on
avait compris que le gouvernement
plafonné à 14% du pib la part des
retraites mais ne se contentant pas de
la stabiliser il programme sa baisse
jusqu'à 12 9 % d'ici 2050
on avait annoncé l'indexation sur
l'évolution des salaires
en réalité les pensions resteront
indexées sur l'inflation et la valeur de
service du point
censé être un accès sur le salaire moyen
serait un excès sur un indicateur
inexistant et non identifiés flagrant
défaut de lisibilité au bout du compte
le fossé entre les slogans et la loi est
béant
le conseil d'état lui même réfute l'idée
d'un régime universel et juge que
l'objectif selon lequel chaque euro
cotisé ouvre les mêmes droits pour tous
reflète imparfaitement la complexité et
la diversité des règles de cotisation ou
d'ouverture de droits définis flagrant
défaut de sincérité quelques mots enfin
sur la réunion de la commission spéciale
le fait par lequel elle a le plus été
spécial et la décision d'arrêter
l'examen du texte sans être arrivé à son
terme
pour respecter l'exigence calendaire
fixés par le gouvernement après la
procédure accélérée
la procédure tronquée vendredi dernier
encore on nous annonçait 46 nouveaux
amendements gouvernementaux de dernière
minute dont deux ordonnances un projet
low additionnel en douce nous sommes
dans une procédure d'exception qui sert
un coup de force flagrant délit de
précipitations au final la constitution
aura été bafoués dans ses articles 34 et
dans son exigence de clarté et de
sincérité de sécurité juridique et
financière de respect des droits du
parlement dans la fragilisation voir la
remise en cause des droits acquis dans
sa conception du principe d'égalité dans
ses principes énoncés au préambule
concernant les garanties dues aux
travailleurs et travailleuses flagrant
délit d'inconstitutionnalité
aujourd'hui le système affiche des
droits garantis pour lesquels on
s'assure des ressources nécessaires si
certaines tensions sont aujourd'hui
insuffisante
certains parcourent mal prises en compte
le projet de loi veut passer à un
système où les droits sont la variable
d'ajustement pour assurer le respect
d'une double règle d'or baisser les
dépenses en maintenant l'équilibré
financier un système où chacun compte
ses points l'âge de départ à taux plein
est programmé pour reculer
génération après génération et menin
mécaniquement pour alimenter une baisse
des pensions
la tension serait calculée sur toute la
carrière alors tout accident de parcours
ce père et par un malus sur la retraite
l'objectif affiché est de voir plus de
seniors plus longtemps dans l'emploi en
les privant ainsi de leurs meilleures
années de retraite et de voir les autres
coûter moins cher puisque la se
cacherait en réalité ce que certains ont
appelé une génération dorée des nantis
tools inverse de ce que défend des
jaurès en vantant la magnifique idée
d'assurance sociale qui crée pour tous
les salariés un droit certains en
appelant à la corriger
et elle a perfectionné flagrant délit
d'un sécurité sociale il s'agit donc
bien d'une réforme d'austérité
financière qui se grime aujourd'hui on
ne modifie pas un critère comme ça même
si vous l'avez fait la réforme autorise
un ajustement paramétrique permanent
celles et ceux qui le pourront seront
ainsi encouragés à des démarches
individuelles jusqu'à la capitalisation
enfin de nourrir les appétits
destructeur de la finance qui rodent
d'autant plus depuis la loi pacte tout
l' inverse du cours de l'histoire
dix ans à réduire et partager le temps
de travail dans la journée la semaine la
vie entre les femmes les hommes toutes
générations tools inverse d'une
dynamique
visant à changer le travail a attaqué sa
pénibilité que certains préfèrent ne pas
voir et non pas à le précarisés et à le
dégrader flagrant délit de régression
sociale meilleur pour les femmes c'est
faux meilleur pour les précaires c'est
faux meilleur pour les carrières plates
c'est faux les seuls points positifs
réside dans les corrections apportées du
niveau au nouveau système pour limiter
ces dégâts et qui auraient pu être
apportées dans le cadre actuel
c'est le cas par exemple pour les
agriculteurs pour la pension minimum que
finalement le projet ne traite pas avec
beaucoup d'ambition et d'ailleurs pour
les agriculteurs il laisse de côté les
retraités actuels le régime général sera
l'exception individuels avec des
inégalités sans justification entre
générations comme en leur sein il
apparaît ainsi que ce système ne serait
ni plus universel ni plus justes ni plus
égalitaire il plus solidaire ni plus
lisible ni plus sûres il serait plus
économe plus économe avec nos vies il
apparaît ainsi un flagrant défaut de
république on ne saurait agir avec
autant de légèreté sur un sujet aussi
sensible on ne saurait légiférer sur nos
retraites à la hâte à la hussarde à
l'aveuglette
sauf à risquer le fiasco on ne saurait
voir bafouer autant d'institutions et de
règles démocratiques
on ne saurait enfin décidées contre le
peuple au nom duquel nous sommes
rassemblés depuis deux mois et demi un
mouvement porte avec détermination le
refus d'une réforme dont chacun a
compris la portée pour toute la vie
cette réforme n'a pas de majorité
populaire dans ce moment
particulièrement la responsabilité
personnelle de chacune et chacun est
engagé entre flagrant délit flagrant
défaut et fariboles rarement une loi
aura autant mérité le rejet
rarement un film aura été aussi pénible
libérer les acteurs coupé
merci chers collègues sur le vote de la
motion de rejet préalable
je suis saisi par le groupe socialiste
et apparentés d'une demande de scrutin
public le scrutin est annoncée dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président je suis le
député pierre dharréville je vais pas
être très long pour répondre à cette
motion de rejet préalable
le gouvernement compte bien non
seulement qu'il soit procédé à l'examen
de l'intégralité des deux textes qui
vous ont été soumis mais également que
ces de texte soit adopté par l'assemblée
nationale vous opposer à ce projet de
loi qui vise à instaurer un système
universel de retraite soit est pourquoi
au curry recourir à cette motion
monsieur le député dharréville alors je
voudrais peut-être reprendre vos mots
pour vous montrer que je vous ai écouté
avec intérêt
je veux pas croire qu'il s'agisse ici
d'un flagrant défaut de débat
démocratique
que signifie au fond cette motion de
rejet préalable du groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
que signifient les milliers
d'amendements monsieur le député de
suppression que vous et votre groupe
avait déposé
autre objectif il est assumé
ralentir bloquer le débat et moi vous le
savez car j'ai été où il ya peu de temps
encore sur ses bancs je veux respecter
le parlement et ses prérogatives je vous
entends des avec d'autres groupes vous
insurgez avec force et vigueur
kan lors des jours réservés à
l'opposition il ya quelques mois
dévotion de rejet ou de renvoi en
commission étaient déposés puis adopté
c'est cette majorité
sur proposition de monsieur le président
richard ferrand je vais vous en
remercier monsieur le président au nom
de la démocratie parlementaire qui a mis
un terme au motion de rejet ou de renvoi
lors de ces journées parlementaires
et vous savez ce que ça a pu vouloir
dire pour notre majorité ces derniers
temps mais nous l'assumons
donc vous savez monsieur le député de la
ville au nom du gouvernement je peux
vous dire que nous assumons le débat sur
notre projet mon souhait c'est de
continuer à examiner l'ensemble des
amendements y compris ceux ci sont
constructives des oppositions dont les
vôtres nous avons adopté en commission
nous pourrons le faire en séance aussi
alors que le disait michel rocard à
grandes causes grande controverse
j'appelle donc un vote contre cette
motion de rejet préalable et pour un
débat la participation de chacun et
rockies
vous pouvez compter sur mon engagement
sur ses bancs je pense que vous avez pu
le constater lors de la commission
spéciale alors mesdames et messieurs les
députés insoumis républicain communistes
socialistes de liberté territoire de
l'idée agir du modem de la république en
marche non-inscrits mesdames et
messieurs les députés des bateaux
merci monsieur le ministre je vais donc
passer aux explications
s'il vous plaît mais ne soyez pas si
agitée nous allons donc passer aux
explications aux explications de vote
je ne crois pas j'ai inscrit pour deux
minutes
monsieur boris vallot pour le groupe
socialiste que vous écoute évidemment
silence parce que l'interrompent est pas
tout le monde y compris vos propres
orateurs et la parole j'attends le
silence complet de mes camarades bon non
simplement monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres
cette réforme est celle du cynisme de
l'esbrouffe et de l'improvisation celle
du cynisme lorsque vous citez à tour de
bras les pères fondateurs de la sécurité
sociale pour hendaye voyez l'héritage
parce que la vérité c'est que pour la
première fois depuis 1945 on calculera
ces retraites non seulement pas
seulement sur la durée de cotisation
mais sur un âge de départ et vous avez
décidé de ce choix funeste pour les plus
modestes que d'instaurer un âge
déquilibre avec son cortège d'inégalités
cynisme aussi lorsque vous aligner les
bons mots l'équité la justice l'égalité
la redistribution mais qui masque mal
vos mauvaises manières cynisme lorsque
vous en appeler au dialogue social ou
lorsque vous espérez du débat
parlementaire alors que chacun sait le
tour de force que vous avez accompli en
mettant après deux ans de concertation
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
dans la rue et que l'on sait depuis deux
ans et demi le peu de cas que vous
faites du débat parlementaire cynisme
lorsque vous prétendez une réforme de
progrès alors qu'on en mesure déjà les
régressions
cette réforme est aussi celle de
l'esbrouffe celle de l'esbrouffe de
votre étude d'impact qui n'est ni fait
ni à faire
c'est l'avis du conseil d'état c'est
l'avis de beaucoup d'économistes dont
certains mots furent proches
c'est aussi de tous ceux qui de bonne
foi ont assisté aux débats en commission
des affaires spéciales esbroufe de vaud
cathy puisqu'ils sont tous escamoté
truqué ou tronquées et qu'ils sont par
définition de ce faux esbroufe sont vos
perspectives financières pour peu que
vous ne veniez bien nous en donner sur
vos progrès sur les promesses faites aux
professeurs tout ça n'est qu'une vaste
et bruay ce bouffon n'y a que quelques
vérités la seule règle d'or celle
équilibre financier se sera la règle de
plomb pour tous les retraités
la seule certitude c'est qu'il nous
faudra travailler ou plus ou gagner moi
voilà la promesse qui vous et qui vous
est fait
et puis enfin c'est une référence
d'amateurisme cette réforme n'est pas
prête
vous n'êtes pas prêt vous improvisez
vous piloter à vue au doigt mouillé
retirer cette réforme c'est le meilleur
coup puis six revers sur sa survie aux
députés la parole est à madame agnès
firmin le bodo pour le groupe u10 à j
avais indépendant merci monsieur le
président notre groupe ne se retirera
une heure pas cette motion de rejet
défendue par le groupe gdr nous plaidons
depuis longtemps pour un système de
retraite par points à la fois plus juste
et plus lisible pour les assurés
comment s'opposer à une réforme qui
prévoit enfin une revers revalorisation
des agriculteurs comment s'opposer à une
réforme qui prévoit un minimum de
retraite à 1000 euros dès 2022
comment s'opposer à une réforme qui est
enfin l'occasion de robes revaloriser
les salaires des enseignants et des
chercheurs
comment enfin s'opposer à une réforme
qui favorise les petites retraites et
qui sera plus redistributive le système
universel constitue un outil essentiel
pour recréer de la confiance entre
générations lutter contre la défiance en
rognant autre système plus lisible et
moins opaque
alors que le débat était en partie
confisqués en commission spéciale
nous nous réjouissons d'avoir le débat
en séance publique à bhl nous avons tous
des amendements apportés sur tous les
bancs place au débat merci chers
collègues la parole à madame jeanine
dubié pour le groupe liberté territoire
oui merci messieurs le président sujet
de la retraite c'est aussi l'assurance
pour quelqu'un qui arrive au bout de sa
carrière d'avoir un taux de remplacement
qui soit correct et d'avoir des
ressources qui lui permettent de vivre
convenablement la dernière partie de sa
vie
avec le texte qui nous est proposé il
n'y a que des incertitudes
nous ne savons pas où nous allons vous
ne nous avez pas convaincu pendant
l'examen en commission d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre a évoqué un nouvel
indice pour
pour le point de service un disque qui
n'existe toujours pas dont on ne sait
pas qu'est ce qu'ils recouvrent comme
réalité 29 ordonnance 29 ordonnance dont
on n'apprécie pas les contours dont on
ne voit pas vrai en tout cas si nous
avions pu aller si vous étiez allé au
bout des négociations avec l'ensemble
des régimes concernés transformer 42
régime en un seul régime
c'est vrai que c'est une c'est un gros
travail qui méritait davantage
d'approfondissement davantage de travail
de de coopération et de concertation
avec l'ensemble des parties concernées
la précipitation du gouvernement
pourquoi ça ça restera pour pour moi en
tout cas mystère pourquoi ces deux dates
17 février 3 mars
voilà deux dates qui nous ont qui ont
poussé effectivement à agir dans la
précipitation et dans l'urgence alors
qu'il ya encore des négociations qui se
poursuivent
toutes ces incertitudes tous ces points
altère la confiance et cette réforme
pour qu'elle soit acceptée consentis il
aurait fallu de la confiance pour toutes
ces raisons le groupe liberté territoire
votera cette motion de rejet préalable
merci madame le député la parole est à
monsieur le président jean luc mélenchon
aujourd'hui commence le débat
parlementaire sur la plus terrible
régression sociale de toute la vème
république
entendons le tricky monde du pays contre
elle celui des traminots des cheminots
des gaziers des électriciens des
danseurs des professeurs des avocats des
héritiers
il donne l'écho de cette interminable
bataille dans la chaîne du temps pour
réduire le temps de travail dans la
journée dans la semaine dans l'année et
dans la vie cette aile de l'assemblée
s'honore d'avoir toujours entendu ce
message et d'en avoir été souvent
l'avant-garde la journée de travail à 8h
c'est nous la semaine à 43 35 heures
c'est nous les cinq semaines de congés
payés c'est nous la retraite à 60 ans
c'est nous
et toutes ces choses sont des fêtes par
vous renoncez à l'une l'inhumanité de
forcer le travail après l'âge
essayez la souveraineté du peuple
demandez-lui par voie référendaire
d'avoir le dernier mot et pas et de
trancher le désaccord complet qu'il ya
entre nous quelle que soit l'ampleur du
feu de vociférations et de vos
propagande mensongère
nous tiendrons la tranche et aussi
longtemps qu'il le faudra et jusqu'à la
victoire
parce que le peuple a toujours eu raison
contre vous visez réactionnaire merci et
je déduis que votre groupe votera donc
cette motion sur le président j'aurais
mal compris monsieur le président je
crois que nous allons voter pour cette
notion c'est bien clair merci de l'avoir
précisé même si salée sans dire ça va
mieux en le disant
la parole est à monsieur gabriel
serville merci président merci mes chers
collègues le projet que le gouvernement
soumet à débat cet après-midi et
regrettablement confus et bâclée
prétendument universel il revient en
réalité sur des décennies de luttes
sociales pour accentuer encore les
privilèges d'une infime partie de la
population
on nous explique que la concertation a
eu lieu que les français se sont
exprimés dans les urnes en 2017 que des
ordonnances et pourquoi pas le 49-3
suffisent désormais mais ce n'est pas ça
la démocratie ce n'est pas laisser une
poignée de hauts fonctionnaires dans les
privilèges sans garantie décidé seul de
l'avenir du pays et des millions de
travailleurs
les français et leurs représentants sur
ces demandes doivent être écoutés ce
n'est manifestement pas le cas
ne serait ce qu'à l'observation de la
fin tragique qui a été réservé à la
commission spéciale l'avenir de notre
système de retraite
l affaire de tous et cette réforme ne
doit pas être confisqué par quelques-uns
la motion de rejet que nous présentons
doit permettre de reprendre la réforme
par étapes en respectant toutes les
procédures propres à un état de droit en
commençant par le rôle du parlement dans
l'élaboration de son contenu c'est la
seule façon avec l'adoption d'une motion
référendaire pour que nous puissions
changer de paradigme et inscrire cette
réforme dans une démarche de justice et
d'équité susceptibles de garantir un
taux de remplacement est levée et
prévisible pour tous de corriger les
inégalités du monde du travail de créer
des outils nouveaux en matière de
reconnaissance de la pénibilité
d'assurer un haut niveau de solidarité
en reconnaissant les périodes de chômage
de formation et d'implication familial
et surtout de garantir des ressources
suffisantes au profit du système en
réaffirmant la place essentielle de la
cotisation sociale
oui il faut nous laisser le temps de co
construire une vraie réforme ambitieuse
juste et de progrès social
c'est à dire celles que les français
attendent alors oui nous voterons pour
cette motion et nous invitons l'ensemble
des collègues aient compris notamment
ceux de la majorité en faire de même
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à monsieur stanislas
guérini merci
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
eh bien nous nous voterons contre cette
motion de rejet
pour une raison simple nous voulons un
débat
nous voulons un débat utile nous voulons
un débat à la hauteur des enjeux
nous voulons un débat démocratique et
nous ne laisserons personne volé ce
débat que le pays mérite car ce débat
ce sera un rendez vous de l'histoire
sociale de notre pays et je vous le dis
avec un peu de tristesse pour l'histoire
des communistes
vous n'êtes pas à la hauteur de
l'histoire sociale du pays
vous n'êtes pas à la hauteur de votre
histoire celle d'ambroise croizat que
vous avez cités celle de maurice thorez
celle du conseil national de la
résistance
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec tout c'est
normal c'est normal si vous étiez
d'accord avec tout nous serions sur les
mêmes bancs mais vous n'avez être
d'accord avec rien ça je ne peux pas le
croire
je ne peux pas croire que vous soyez
pour une retraite minimale
je ne peux me croire que vous soyez
contre un système qui va diminuer
l'écart entre les retraites des plus
pauvres et celle des plus riches
je ne peux pas croire que vous soyez
contre un système qui va donner plus de
droits aux femmes dès le premier enfant
eh bien nous nous ne serons au rendez
vous de ces grandes conquêtes sociales
et si j'osais si j'osais je citerai
maurice thorez mauvaise torres disait
qu'il vaut mieux s'unir pour obtenir le
bonheur sur la terre que se disputait
sur l'existence d'un paradis dans le
ciel et bien je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire comment je comprends moi cette
citation c'est très simple pour moi la
gauche qui ne fait rien elle ne sert à
rien la gauche qui s'oppose à tout elle
ne sert à rien du tout
alors fini son genre avec les manoeuvres
finissons-en avec l'obstruction
car vous avez emboîté le pas de nos
camarades communistes des bâtons et
songeons travaillons c'est ça être au
rendez vous de l'histoire
merci monsieur le député
[Applaudissements]
la parole s'il vous plaît la parole est
à monsieur le président damien abad
s'il vous plaît vous avez la parole
fallait merci monsieur le président vous
dire que sur cette motion le groupe est
républicain ne prendra pas part au vote
car nous ne voulons pas de confusion
politique entre les oppositions parce
que les solutions voulu ne sont pas les
mêmes que les notes vous le savez
malheureusement messieurs les ministres
votre réforme est mauvaise et n'en
déplaise au président de la république
c'est aujourd'hui votre amateurisme qui
va coûter cher aux français c'est votre
amateurisme qui conduira et on le sait
au 49 3 et au déni de démocratie et ce
sera votre waterloo politique c'est
votre amateurisme qui a fait que les
études d'impact et les études préalables
ne sont que des projections financières
lacunaire comme le dit le conseil d'état
c'est votre amateurisme également qui
malheureusement a entraîné un recours
massif aux ordonnances là vous aviez la
possibilité de présenter un projet de
loi digne de ce nom et c'est votre
amateurisme qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
votre réforme elle est mauvaise elle a
mis tout le monde dans la rue et au delà
de cela elle est injuste elle est
coûteuse elle est surtout trop complexe
et nous avons nous les républicains fait
un contre projet parce que nous sommes
une opposition responsable et
constructive et nous vous avions dit que
nous voulions supprimer les régimes
spéciaux dans un délai raisonnable et
que nous voulions par contre maintenir
les régimes complémentaires et autonome
au nom de quoi on doit s'en prendre
aujourd'hui aux avocats aux professions
libérales aux indépendants à celles et
ceux qui ne coûte pas un euro d'argent
public aux français et que vous
aujourd'hui
vous stigmatisez alors messieurs les
ministres oui nous voulons le débat
simplement ce débat vous nous aurions pu
la voir dans des bonnes conditions
si le gouvernement avait revu recours au
temps législatif programmé
s'il avait respecté les six semaines de
délai et si par un préparation et parade
motorisée
il n'avait pas justement reculé
aujourd'hui cette obstruction
parlementaire vous êtes co responsable
parce que nous n'avait pas agi
suffisamment tôt et parce que vous
n'avez pas assumer cette réforme des
retraites alors chez les républicains
nous voulons un vrai débat apaisé
responsable déterminé
et avec un vrai contre projet sur la
table et des propositions qui seront
soumises devant les français merci
monsieur le président la parole est à
monsieur jean paul mattei
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le ministre un
instant vous nous proposer de débattre
nous on veut débattre au modem vous
conviendrait quand même que on a un
petit goût d'amertume après cette
commission spéciale qui a duré 75 eur et
vous conviendrait également vous
conviendra également que vingt mille
amendements
vingt mille amendements dont certains
viser la suppression d'un chapitre d'une
section d'un paragraphe
franchement on peut avoir des
amendements sur le fond et on
souhaiterait qu on puisse débattre sur
le fond
donc on peut pas on peut pas à la fois
reprocher que le système est engorgé et
et mettre tous ses amendements qui ne
régule pas les flux on peut le regretter
alors bien évidemment leur au modem ne
votera pas cette motion de rejet parce
qu'on pense profondément que ce texte
même s'il est à parfaire d'un texte
juste qui c'est un texte juste qu est
équilibré on a pu s'en rendre compte
avec le travail en commissions qu'on a
pu avoir et je crois qu'il est
nécessaire qu'on vis-à-vis de du peuple
français qu'on ait un débat apaisé et
serein sur un texte effectivement qui va
engager des générations futures
et je crois qu'il est essentiel qu'on se
pose et qu'on réfléchisse est vraiment
nous souhaitons pouvoir débattre sur le
fond pour le bien de l'ensemble des
français pour préparer un régime un
régime plus juste plus lisible pour les
générations futures
merci monsieur le député nous allons
maintenant procéder au scrutin je vais
donc mettre aux voix
la motion de rejet préalable
je vous prie de bien vouloir gagner vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 215
exprimer 213 majorité 107 pour 68 contre
145 la motion de rejet préalable n'ait
pas adopté
la séance est suspendue pour cinq
minutes
[Applaudissements]